all right it's time for this week's sin
city chronicles a weekly look back at
vegas history and happenings
and the arena football league ran from
1987 to 2019
in las vegas was home to five arena bowl
championship games
one of the big ones was on june 12 2005
at the thomas and mack when john elway's
colorado crush
defeated georgia force 51-48 to win
arena bowl 19.
the game came down to a field goal with
no time left on the clock check it out
[Applause]
it was an action-packed game and
included a half-time performance
from brian adams
[Music]
david lee roth he left van halen in 1985
and june 9 1988 he brought his solo act
to las vegas
the skyscraper tour sold out to thomas
and mack
poison was the opening act and roth put
on a show at one point
he actually repelled down from the
ceiling of the arena
before go knights go it was go flash go
back in june 1994 we were cheering on
our las vegas flash
roller hockey team the flash were part
of roller hockey international
we're actually looking at the all-star
game from that year
the flash played their games at the
thomas and mack ken morrow an olympic
gold medal winner with the 1980 miracle
on ice team
coached the flash the team only lasted
one season and then the league
folded in 1999.
what are you doing here you ought to be
out there celebrating right now i'm
challenging you to a fight
anytime anyplace anywhere oh tommy gunn
in 1990 tommy morrison was the star of
rocky five
and three years later on june 7 1993
he was facing off against george foreman
at the thomas and mack
now the fight was billed as the star
spangled battle
the men were fighting for the
heavyweight championship morrison
actually defeated foreman
by unanimous decision look at those two
heavyweights
just going at it all right that's your
sin city chronicles for the second week
of june